[Música]
ya estamos otra vez en directo a América
edición nocturna con nuestra sección
directo hay en esta ocasión nos vamos
hasta Estados Unidos desde Nueva York
nuestra corresponsal mamen sala nos
ampliaba previamente sobre las tormentas
de nieve que azotan el oeste del estado
de Nueva York y otros estados
circundantes a la región de los grandes
lagos que se despertaron ya este viernes
con acumulaciones de más de medio metro
de nieve las tormentas podrían durar
hasta el domingo y dejar acumulados
históricos para la fecha le preguntamos
a nuestra corresponsal Cuál es la
situación actual por estas primeras
Nevadas de la temporada en el estado de
Nueva York
Sí aquí la situación es cada vez más
complicada ya hay alrededor de 6
millones de personas que se encuentran
bajo alerta por tormenta de nieve en
cinco estados en los grandes lagos desde
Wisconsin hasta Nueva York aquí la peor
parte se la está llevando Búfalo allí
las autoridades han dicho que se trata
de una tormenta histórica que no se veía
algo igual desde el 2014 cuando
precisamente una tormenta de nieve acabó
con la vida de 20 personas es lo que han
dicho las autoridades para que los
ciudadanos se hagan una idea de lo
peligrosa que es la situación de hecho
la gobernadora del estado de Nueva York
Katy ha decretado el estado de
emergencia en al menos 11 condados en
estos momentos como digo la peor parte
se la está llevando Búfalo y seguirá
avanzando cada vez a peor a medida que
nos acerquemos a la noche Allí se han
cerrado escuelas a lo largo del día de
hoy se han cerrado oficinas se han
cerrado carreteras incluso carreteras
principales porque la cantidad de nieve
que estaba cayendo y la intensidad era
tal que ni siquiera las máquinas
quitanieves más fuertes han podido
limpiar las carreteras además también se
han suspendido varios vuelos y las
autoridades no se cansan de repetir a
los ciudadanos que no salgan de su casa
y que por supuesto No cojan el coche
también le consultamos que prevé el
servicio meteorológico nacional para
este fin de semana y Cómo se preparan
los estados para enfrentar este fenómeno
la peor parte como decías se la está
llevando Búfalo Pero a medida que avance
el fin de semana en Nueva York podría
convertirse también junto con Búfalo en
la Zona cero de esta tormenta de nieve
los servicios meteorológicos nacionales
ya han dicho que nos acercamos a un fin
de semana de mucho frío con unas
temperaturas 20 grados por debajo de lo
que estaba previsto para estos dos días
y con bastantes tormentas de nieve ahí
en Búfalos se llevan la peor parte las
autoridades insisten en que los
ciudadanos se queden en sus casas y
muchos ya han comenzado a las
palas para sacar las para sacar la nieve
de delante de las puertas de su casa y
pera y para que cuando llegue el frío y
esa nieve se convierta en hielo no los
deja encerrado en sus propios hogares
muchos también han comprado provisiones
para al menos dos o tres días porque el
servicio meteorológico nacional asegura
que esto podría durar hasta el domingo
allí en Búfalo lo peor de ese efecto
lago que estamos viendo va a tener lugar
el efecto lago es cuando el frío viento
sopla encima de los lagos con una
temperatura un poquito más alta Y
entonces ese frío absorbe la humedad de
los lagos como una esponja creando unas
nubes que crean tormentas que en vez de
ser eléctricas son tormentas de nieve y
eso es lo que vamos a ver durante todo
el fin de semana hasta el domingo